unless someone's trying to launch their
own career right but at that point it's
like what do you want to do do you want
to write you want to act you in a draft
because I can guarantee you're not good
at all three of them I mean and I know
you know there's Woody Allen is alive
and still making movies and guys like Ed
Burns and those guys are around but you
know
odds are you're either gonna be a great
actor and not exactly have the good
directors eye you're gonna be very
visually great with communication and a
palette but when it comes time for you
to act you know your mind is weight you
know thinking about angles and where
what you're gonna do you know what's
after that scene cuz you got a whole day
of like all these you know you have a
shoot day to get through so well that
reminds me of your video interview you
did with Webster University your alma
mater and you said that someone coming
from film school or any type of creative
you know career excuse me seeking a
creative degree should really pinpoint
what it is that they want to do mm-hmm
and not just yeah under the guise of
this or that but because you said it's
really tough and and I want to hear more
about your process for choosing you said
you wanted to just write in direct mm-hm
and why is it so tough well I picked the
toughest thing writing and directing
that's the hardest I think they're all
hard and they all the you know you need
everyone you need the collaborative
effort to get to get the picture made
it's important because there's to MIT
there's too much competition and there's
too many people too good at their jobs
for you to think you can do everything
if you think you can be your own DP your
own director be in your own movie then
then you have you haven't been on enough
sets period I mean I was a PA when I was
a 17 18 years old on a
big film and you see how dedicated now
professional these people are from the
boom operator to the key grip to the cam
to the first AC to the script D they're
so passionate and dedicated to think
that you can be good at everything is
ridiculous I mean it's just it's like
only in the entertainment business do we
think we can do everything you don't see
a you know a doctor saying well I'm good
at brain surgery and I'm a
parapsychologist and I can go sell cars
or or you know it's just so it's
important to figure out what you're good
at what's gonna get you up in the
morning if you want if you get up in the
morning and you really feel like man I
really like being a boom op I like being
close to the actors I like that I like
you know you know that's what I get
passionate about going to set every
morning that's what you should do for me
I like the communication the aspect of
communicating with the actors developing
that relationship that's that's my thing
that's what I do best that's why I
direct and writing kind of and I'm you
know that kind of goes hand in hand
reminds me of the saying jack of all
trades master of none
so you're watering down you know the
whole creative process you talked about
in the interview that things will get
difficult can you talk about what that
is like what did you mean when you said
that in the interview because I thought
that was interesting things look it
difficult things are gonna get difficult
because you're gonna realize how the a
how competitive it is and B how how
truly how good people really are at
their jobs and how not only have to be
good at your job bring something to the
table you have to be accountable you
have to be reliable and you have to be a
good person to work with and I think
those are a lot of dynamics thrown into
the mix and because there's always if
you don't want to do it there's always
going to be someone else that will
that'll come in right behind you and do
your job
you